and part of the reason we're having this
difficulty with social cohesion is
because we're we're social animals that
depend on an imaginary order in our head
we depend on believing the same story as
a way to feel like we're in a tribe
together and it's imagination it's a
story it's in your head and so when
there was only one guy telling everybody
what to think and feel was very easy to
put one story into everybody's head and
you could tell if you were on this team
with somebody if you believed the same
story now we've got many talking to many
and the amount of stories and narratives
that are out there are just in you know
infinite basically and so now there's
gonna be like an infinite number of
tribes and so we have a breakdown in
social cohesion which for a large nation
of ours social cohesion is really
important we're not just living we're
not living in a small little 30 person
tribe where we have one story that we
believe and we can live together based
on that you know we're 300 some million
people and the mess up in most difficult
part is that your tribe isn't your
neighbor your tribe is actually some guy
that lives in Minnesota
another guy's in California another guy
that lives in London and so your tribe
isn't your geographic tribe anymore so
now you got to rub shoulders everyday
with people that aren't your tribe so
here's here's what I think Republicans
are gonna win they are they're affected
less by the rapid progression of media
than the left is partly due to the lack
of high-speed Internet in many rural
areas that are typically conservative so
there's a couple factors here that's one
another factor is a shared identity
under Trump Trump is the dude yes but
also nationalism so nationalism is that
that imagine order that story that
people can rally behind and that I had a
conversation on my podcast with a
gentleman named I'm getting old just the
name just jumped right out of my brain
oboe Weingard sorry bye sorry bow where
we talked about how nationalism was like
a cure for social cohesion it's like we
didn't have we weren't talking about
nationalism before but now we are
because people need it they need it they
need it because they need an identity
you need something to bring people
together and you know for me when I hear
nationalism to me it's like American
citizens it's not about race it's not
about
it's not about you know how long have
you been in the country it's about are
you an American citizen and do you like
believe in the flag that's it that's the
day okay the Democrats have in their
caucus people that hate America yep in
the Republican Party they're basically
all like yay America yeah okay
that's almost good enough for me right I
don't want to be on a team with people
that hate America who believe that the
whole thing is a racist oppression
machine starting from 1619 it's a
perfectly designed in order to keep
black people down nevermind that was big
news and never mind
never mind the fact that like Nigerian
and other African American immigrants
the United States are like the
highest-earning people that come to its
tea or that or that some of the people
I'm a great to hear away later right
like my family came here I know I'm not
coming from black black family my family
came here in the past like 150 years or
something yeah you know so so I
understand the whole immigrant argument
but we weren't I wasn't a part of that
they try to rope it in though right so I
don't want to be a part of a party that
hates America so so nationalism you made
a really good point
I can look to the Conservatives in the
right and and identify one word can you
can you look to the Democrats and
identify a single word hate I mean I I
think that's that's obviously none of
them are saying they want to hate yeah
but there is a strong hatred of the
progressives to the establishment the
establishment to the Socialists both to
Trump then to you know siz white at a
normative patriarchy it's like but but
in all seriousness the love where's the
love that's what I want to know I love
America nationalism I love America I
love all Americans go America
let's take care of America love that's
love make America great again that's
love there's love in there but but but I
decided let's do this
I think it's fair to say would it be
fair to say 100 percent of Trump
supporters nationalism pretty much yeah
like obviously it's 99 point something
there'd be a few people who are like the
acceleration is maybe yeah if you said
the word Democrat is there a single
policy or mission or idea that brings
them all together I there's nothing
coming to mind answers I can I can make
some you know makes my guess is you know
definitely intersectional race stuff
know
nope not even true well right it doesn't
unify the party right yeah look at Joe
Biden intersectional doesn't play to him
Medicare fraud doesn't play to him
social doesn't play to him even Warren
said you reject socialism she's a
capitalist globalism isn't it I've heard
people say that it's a it's globalist
versus nationalists but the Democrats
literally don't champion globalism not
walking around saying one world a new
order or something know what they do
through their policy prescription many
of them do right and and and that's one
of the things that's been scary is that
going back to the point I was making
about how Republicans have been a bit
immunized from the rapid altering of
media the reason the Democratic part in
the debate stage raised their hand to
give non-citizens taxpayer-funded health
care is because they're being rapidly
radicalized by these various social
media platforms yeah it's mostly Twitter
where you have a tiny pocket of Fringe
activists who are extremely loud
but who will threaten you and destroy
you if you cross the line yeah so here's
here's my thing man I've never been uh
uh I'll tell you this in 2016 I was
sitting across from Cassandra Fairbanks
big Trump supporter is she still like no
I don't I don't think so not anymore
yeah she's over life the Trump yeah over
like Assange and stuff probably right
yeah but but she was super ready for
Trump to win and I am I am just so over
the cheating the cronyism of the DNC
that when Trump won I just started
laughing I'm like this is our world this
is what they get it was like comeuppance
I didn't vote for the guy but I felt a
certain satisfaction in Hillary Clinton
losing after what they did in the
primaries that's not democracy so I've
always been it been in that position but
it's never been hard for me to have a
conversation with someone like you or to
recognize that there's a bunch of
hateful violent crazy people with crazy
ideas and crazy ideology slowly
encroaching over the Democratic Party is
but I'll tell you this I held out I held
out hope and it's shattered with the
Iowa caucus that's cute to me I know I
know I know I know but I was like look
man I know that Andrew yang Tulsi
Gabbard probably weren't going to win
but I hope that for various reasons them
on the debate stage would would do
something to the Democratic Party I to a
certain extent can can like Buddha judge
over his more rational approach to
policy ideas but even he is not
particularly moderate where the
Democrats used to be and it's not even
about that to be honest it's about the
rigging the failure is the ineptitude
the the media smears the lies it's just
I'm out I'm done
I think actually I've been thinking
about your question as you're talking I
wasn't listening I'm thinking in my head
of course right uh if feminism I think
is something that all those candidates
can unify behind thinking like they
believe that they're feminists right
they're feminists and there's a lot that
goes in that it leads to a lot of
disastrous policy ideas it leads to you
know de-risking of the economy it leads
to slower innovation and sciences and
Industry it leads to a million different
things at least to destruction of the
nuclear family it leads to the lower
marriage rates it leads to you know
lower fertility rates it leads to women
being in their thirties not finding a
mate because they make too much money
and men aren't going to college anymore
so I think I think feminism actually is
probably one of the more unifying
factors about all of those candidates
and I think that it's actually one of
the things that's leading to a number of
problems and let me just make this
perfectly clear I fully believe that
every woman should have all the rights
they need to have all the rights
everyone should have you should be able
to do whatever they want everything that
you know perfectly equal in terms of
under the law and equal opportunity and
all that I'm talking about radical
feminism now and sort of the long-term
effects of what happens when you stop
prioritizing family units in America and
start prioritizing individual
achievement irrespective of sort of
family which is I think what we're
starting to see and maybe we'll talk
about this a little bit later it's like
what is what does it look like in the
dating and mating markets what does it
look like for women that are thirty five
have a college degree make six years and
can't find a can't find a man let's
let's jump in it in about a minute let
me ask you a question though in terms of
the unifying factors of both parties
define feminism define feminism yeah as
you see it like the way you're looking
at what unifies the Democrats right what
does that word mean well to me feminism
means that there should be an equal
outcome for everyone so that everyone
should be able to make any the same
money socialism or
have all the same interest believed all
the same things have the same tendencies
the same proclivities the same
psychological makeup
there's no allowance for individuality
or differences between the genders and I
think that this is something that's
really driving a wedge in between people
that see the world rationally and
understand that men are bigger and women
are smaller and men like to take risks
and women like to care take these are
broad generalizations right when you
make pop when you put them all in a
population these are real things the
Democrats deny all of that okay and it's
not just the Democrats it's in Google
it's in to our search algorithms it's in
every corporate HR department in America
where if you don't have half-and-half
50/50 then you're doing something wrong
you're a bigot sir you're not bigoted
sir because there's not 50% women and
men here as trash collectors and minors
okay so I don't say that so I have a
simple question that actually will help
someone understand what's wrong with
that ideology you're a six foot four
five six or five in the boots maybe and
how much do you weigh I'm about 245 ask
I'm asking each and every one of you
listening or watching would you rather
have six foot four 200 in 44 45 pound
Jack Murphy kicked the door into a
burning building where you're crawling
desperate for life or a five-foot five
hundred and thirty pound woman right I'm
not saying that that women can't be
firefighters there are a small faction
of women who tend to be taller and
stronger and they pass a test they do it
my sister was Barford yeah and and and
that's the truth about equality that
anyone should be allowed the opportunity
to try but there are some roles in our
society that you're gonna want six foot
four dude solving a problem you can't be
a Democrat and have that positioned
exactly exactly
and that's what my you know Tulsi tried
doing the olive branch of Republicans
they ate her alive Hillary Clinton came
after her Andrew yang has tried saying
stop complaining about Trump all day
he's not the cause of our problems they
keep they booed him from some of the
debates they won't listen to him he's
not gonna I could I couldn't tell you
told C's like platform but I can tell
you I like her exactly like I don't I
don't I really don't know all the things
she believes in and and I like it it
would be irrational for me to know
because she's never gonna be president
she's not gonna be president at least
the cycle right but I do like her II
like her energy maybe when the Democrats
wake up
from a shocking double defeat with
Donald Trump they might snap out of it
thanks for checking out this segment
from the Tim cast IRL podcast we do the
show every Monday through Friday at 8
p.m. sometimes an hour or two and we do
have a full live recorded version of the
show that includes a lot of comments and
smaller segments you probably don't see
if you want to check that out you can
watch live at 8:00 p.m. Monday through
Friday or become a member of this
channel and for five bucks a month you
get full access to all of the recorded
podcasts every day after the show we
make them available in the community
section of this YouTube channel so don't
forget to subscribe and stick around for
more segments and more shows Monday
through Friday at 8 p.m. thanks for
hanging out and we'll see you all in the
next show
you